♪♪
♪ Milk, milk, lemonade, milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk
lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk
lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ I used to think that
my tits was where it's at ♪
♪ Used to be concerned that
my booty was too fat ♪
♪ But now I know the truth
and that worry has been shot ♪
♪ Big booty's
what they want ♪
♪ And big booty's
what I got ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk
lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk
lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ Tits are old news
if you know what I mean ♪
♪ All the guys love my
fudge machine ♪
♪ Look me in the eye ♪
♪ Get your face in
don't be shy ♪
♪ You say you
don't like asses ♪
♪ 'Cause I fart and break
your glasses ♪
♪ Turd cutter ♪
♪ Loaf pincher ♪
♪ Dookie maker ♪
♪ Fudge machine ♪
♪ Cheek-tastic ♪
♪ Booty Mastiff ♪
♪ Giant tuchus ♪
♪ Fudge machine ♪
♪ On my booty empire ♪
♪ The sun never set ♪
♪ Take a shot ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Nothing but net ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ I'm gonna make
you scream and shout ♪
♪ From the part of my body
where poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where
my poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where my poop
comes out ♪
♪ This is where
my poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where my poop
comes out ♪
♪ Talking about
my fudge machine ♪
♪ Talking about my
fudge machine ♪
♪ Talking about
my fudge machine ♪
♪ Talking about my
fudge machine ♪
That's right, ladies.
Ain't nothing better than a big,
beautiful, sexy booty.
But bottom line,
no matter how fine the behind,
you better call that onion
what it really is.
That shit's a fudge machine.
Turn out.
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk
lemonade ♪
♪ Milk, milk lemonade ♪
♪ 'Round the corner
fudge is made ♪
♪ This is where
her poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where your
poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where
their poop comes out ♪
♪ This is where our
poop comes out ♪
♪ This is what
you think is hot ♪
♪ This is what you
think is hot ♪
♪ This is what
you think is hot ♪
♪ Talking about my
fudge machine ♪
♪ This is what
you think is hot ♪
♪ This is what you
think is hot ♪
♪ This is what
you think is hot ♪
♪ Talking about my
fudge machine ♪♪